[Musik]
wir beginnen mit einer sternstunde der
menschheit der keilschrift eine der
ältesten schriften der welt
was die babylonier da schrieben am
allerliebsten schrieben sie
verwaltungsvorschriften bürokratie seit
5000 jahren leiden die menschen unter
ihrem bürger griff unendlicher
stillstand impfungen digitale unterricht
schnelltests daran hapert es dafür gibt
es woche für woche neue bürokratische
wort monstren wie abstandsgebot
immunität nachweis und wellenbrecher
lockdown bürokratie das heißt die
herrschaft der regeln sind regeln auf
und hält sich an die regeln oder man
hält sich an die vorschriften und in der
öffentlichen bürokratie ist es ja
zumindest auch so dass deren
vorsichtsprinzip gilt also man möchte
lieber nichts falsch machen das ist ja
auch richtig erst mal nichts falsch
machen sollen aber das führt dann zu
einer sehr vorsichtigen herangehensweise
deutschland das land der zwei
geschwindigkeiten auf der einen seite
bürger und unternehmen die sich rar
auf die pandemie einstellen
improvisieren wo es nur geht
auf der anderen seite die
gesundheitsbürokratie ein beispiel
schnelltests sind zu 97 zuverlässig doch
für eine schnelle zulassung reichte das
offenbar monatelang nicht obwohl gerade
jetzt eine pragmatische lösung gefragt
wäre die sehnsucht nach sicherheit ist
manchmal der feind des guten
das gute ist ja meistens das
improvisierte das improvisierte dass
auch bestimmten lokalen erfahrungen
beruht die man in anderen fällen bereits
gemacht hat ich denke da an eine
geschichte die die berühmt geworden ist
aus der italienischen katastrophen
forschung irgendwo in italien vor 10 15
jahren passiert ein größeres erdbeben
und die lokale bevölkerung reagiert
sofort damit dass sie einen espresso
stadt eingerichtet man ist besser stand
weil dort alle zusammen kommen die
irgend auf ungeahnte weise beim räumen
bei medizinischen behandeln
beim versorgen von angehörigen usw
in dieser region katastrophen halber zu
tun haben
doch die geschichte vom espresso stand
geht weiter kaum hatte die bürokratie
davon erfahren machte sie den kaffee
stand dicht wo sich bürokraten
einmischen drehen sich die dinge nur
noch im kreis
doch das kann man auch anders sehen der
berühmte deutsche soziologe max weber
pries die bürokratie einst als das beste
mittel gegen vetternwirtschaft denn das
büro hat einen vorteil hier gibt es
keine freunde gepasst es ist ein anderer
wichtiger soziologe hat mal das amt als
eine der wichtigsten evolutionären
revolutionären errungenschaften der
dement der menschheitsgeschichte
bezeichnet weil nämlich das amt in der
lage ist ein handeln zu motivieren das
nicht durch freundschaft nicht durch
verwandtschaft motiviert sein kann in
dem maß in dem es ans handeln ist und
nicht zuletzt wird der jedermann touch
für das amts handeln gezahlt und zwar
meistens mit geld bezahlt max weber
großen wert gelegt das heißt aus den
ketten der des austausches von
naturalien herausgelöst folgt man max
weber hat die bürokratie einen weiteren
vorteil sie ist berechenbar
aber was heißt das für den umgang mit
einem virus das unberechenbar ist
vielleicht ist dies der kern des
dilemmas die politik setzt ein ziel und
die verwaltung muss es umsetzen
die verwaltung liefert zwar einen
sauberen prozess ab doch für die ziele
ist sie nicht zuständig und wenn auch
die politik das ziel aus den augen
verliert dann klingen unsere politiker
wie die obersten sachbearbeiter der
republik der prozess ist alles das ziel
ist nichts
politik häufig prozessorientiert denkt
sind alle interessen berücksichtigt
worden war dass partizipativ der prozess
und haben wir hinreichend abgewogen und
das ist so auch häufig sag mal die
richtige vorgehensweise demokratie dass
wir das so machen und die unternehmen
sind natürlich eher ergebnisorientiert
oder privatleute für die ist wichtiger
was kommt am ende raus ist es anderswo
besser in den usa wurden schon 75
millionen impfdosen verabreicht das ziel
ist klar und die botschaft auch den
nachschub und verfolgen den klaren plan
300 millionen amerikaner zu impfen
ein unbürokratisches wunderland
mitnichten
gerade in den usa führte jede
liberalisierung zu einer deutlichen
zunahme an bürokratie immer mehr
verwalter die immer weniger verwalten
wenn solche solche eigendynamik von von
bürokratie noch dazukommen dann ist es
vollkommen klar dass dieses wunderbare
instrument der sicherung von kompetenz
sehr schnell zu einem instrument der
immunisierung gegenüber allem was
irgendwie an neuen anforderungen aus der
gesellschaft auftreten könnten könnte
sich entwickelt und dann ist das ist
diese bürokratie entweder überflüssig
weil sie so toll ins match
oder sie steht wie ein klotz in der
landschaft herum und stört jeden an der
vernünftigen arbeit
vernünftige arbeit das hieße alle werden
getestet alle werden geimpft
aber vielleicht ist das ja zu einfach
gedacht